jugendamt vor werbung der bundeskanzler
hat heute gesagt wie und never walk
alone und hat zum beispiel eine
dauerhafte heizkostenpauschale
besprochen ist damit ihre sorge vor
volksaufständen und eine spaltung der
gesellschaft besaitet wir tun alles als
bundesregierung dafür dass wir in dieser
nicht einfachen situation wo wir erleben
müssen dass der russische präsident eben
nicht nur mit waffen krieg führt sondern
auch energie als druckmittel einsetzt
dass wir als gesellschaft geschlossen
zusammenstehen weil das ist eines seiner
ziele gesellschaften demokratien zu
spalten und deswegen ist es ebenso
wichtig dass wir die soziale
unterstützung ist nicht einfach anlage
mitdenken und vor allen dingen auch
vorausschauend unterschiedliche
szenarien sind sie in den vergangenen
tagen und wochen und die falle von
wladimir putin getappt ich hatte so ein
bisschen das gefühl denn das waren ja
panik setzte eigentlich die sie gesagt
haben und andere gesagt haben und er
sieht doch jetzt eigentlich mensch
erwerber und andere in der regierung
deutschland sowieso habe ich total in
der hand sich komplett anders und wir
sind in keine falle getappt sondern wir
bereiten uns seit monaten bestmöglich
darauf vor dass auch energie von dem
russischen präsidenten als waffe
eingesetzt wird und auch mit blick auf
die formulierung die ich gewählt habe
ich hab mir bewusst gesagt zugespitzt
das bezog sich jetzt nicht auch nur
stream 1 sondern das bezog sich in der
diskussion darauf dass ich deutlich
gemacht habe hätten wir ganz zu beginn
des krieges als es forderungen gab mit
einem ölembargo mit einer sofortigen
gasstopp begeben sich die deutsche
bundesregierung gestellt hatte ich auch
persönlich in brüssel der
wirtschaftsminister der bundeskanzler
gesagt haben das geht nicht ich habe in
diesem gespräch deutlich gemacht warum
wir das damals gemacht haben wir damals
hätten wir dann von einem tag auf den
anderen jegliche fossile
gasimporte unterbinden müssen und dann
wäre mir vollkommen unvorbereitet
gewesen das sind wir jetzt nicht wir
haben in den letzten fünf monaten
spüren müssen dass alle möglichen tricks
methoden angewandt werden und deswegen
bereiten uns jetzt eben darauf was im
winter sein dennoch das ziel von
wladimir putin ist ja das narrativ zu
verändern kaum jemand spricht noch über
das leid in der ukraine auch dadurch
dass sie vor volksaufständen gewarnt
haben und andere davor waren wir müssen
energie sparen bedeutet weniger über das
leid in der ukraine gesprochen und mehr
über die angst stress im herbst oder
winter präsident an sorry aber noch mal
ich habe wie gesagt dass rückblickend
warum wir damals kein gas und öl embargo
gemacht haben aber sei es drum mit blick
auf die jetzige situation stimme ich
ihnen vollkommen zu wir erleben in den
letzten wochen zunehmend das über das
leid in der ukraine weniger berichtet
wird da sind auch auf ihren zeitungs
andere titelseiten als noch vor drei
monaten
und daher hatte ich auch schon vor
längerem gesagt wir müssen aufpassen
dass es nicht irgendwie zu seiner
gewohnheit wird tagtäglich sterben
menschen werden zivilisten angegriffen
wir haben ja gerade den bericht bekommt
von der osze noch mal deutlich gemacht
haben wie systematisch dieser russische
präsident jeden ganz bewusst zivilisten
angreifen gräueltaten passieren da war
das theater in mario pohl wo klar war da
sind vor allem familien vor allem kinder
drin trotzdem ganz bewusst bombardiert
streumunition mit eingesetzt bei
angriffen auf dem bahnhof und auch jetzt
nach wie vor die situation auch wenn sie
richtigerweise sagen dass nicht mehr so
viel in der öffentlichkeit davon ist
dass tagtäglich
unschuldige menschen sterben bleibe
putin macht sich über die energiepolitik
der bundesregierung bereits lustig er
hat gesagt vorschläge die bürger sollten
beim duschen mit warmem wasser sparen
sein zitat blödsinn solche politiker
sind für putin zu tat völlig verrückt
geworden damals meinte er offensichtlich
robert habeck also r freut sich über
diese die bahn dass ich freude was meint
ob er was weiß ich was macht es mehr ich
gesagt herzlich egal dieser russische
präsident führt an völkerrechtswidrigen
angriffskrieg gegenüber einem anderen
land der satyr alle methoden ein die den
direkte kriegsführung in der ukraine er
nutzt energie als waffe benutzt getreide
als waffe weil seinen versuch eben ist
unser land zu spalten die europäische
union zu spalten die weltgemeinschaft
die ja in ganz ganz großer mehrheit
diesen brutalen angriffs krieg
verurteilt zu spalten indem er eben mit
blick auf den krieg den er ebenfalls für
die spaltung herbeiführt und das
wichtige ist dass wir uns davon weder
erpressen noch treiben noch sonstwas
lassen sondern in dieser schwierigen
situation und einfach ist es auf gar
keinen fall in größtmöglicher
gemeinsamer verantwortung das tun was
die ukraine unterstützt und seien
zugleich das was unsere menschen in
unserem land schützt und auch weltweit
dafür sorgt dass die nöte der menschen
weltweit nicht noch heftiger werden
halten sie sich selbst an hab ich's
april wieder zu duschen sehen sie die
minuten
manchmal stehe ich zu spät auf dass ich
die sekunden zählen aber ich weiß das
klingt so nach kleinigkeiten aber wie es
in solchen situationen
ist viele kleine schritte bringen eine
auch
leider ist mein zeitplan vorher auch
schon so gewesen dass ich leider nicht
unendlich viel zeit habe man beim
duschen aber natürlich kann jeder darauf
achten wie man energie sparen kann wie
man vor allen dingen gar sparen kann wie
man strom sparen kann und deswegen finde
ich auch falsch dass jetzt ein bisschen
dargestellt wird was soll dieser
kleinkram wie gesagt auch aus kleinen
maßnahmen können wir in der summe
energie einsparen und so nachbarn in den
niederlanden haben dass zum beispiel
vorgemacht jedenfalls wenn ich das
richtig ist was mir berichtet wurde 20
prozent energieeinsparung wurde da
bereits gemacht wir sehen doch auch bei
den menschen im alltag jeder versucht
das bestmögliche zu tun kinder überlegen
in der schule die sieben beitrag leisten
können jetzt im sommer als der
spritpreis so hoch gegangen ist auch mit
dem neuen euro ticket hat das dazu
geführt dass in innenstädten der verkehr
um 20 prozent zurückgegangen ist das
heißt es gibt ja so ein spruch tausend
kleine menschen an tausend kleinen orten
dieser welt könnte sich der welt
verändern und darum geht dass millionen
menschen einstehen gegen diesen brutalen
angriffs krieg in der ukraine und zeigen
wir sind solidarisch und jeder leistet
seinen beitrag und ich glaube die
bevölkerung ist manchmal weiter als
vielleicht die die die politik dass sich
die politik an und sagen dass eben viel
getan werden kann
auch bei diesen energieproblemen was ich
dann logisch nicht verstehe ist warum
die grünen bei der atomkraft zur studie
sind der münchner stadtverband der
grünen hier in münchen hat sich gestern
dafür ausgesprochen das akw isar 2 für
einige monate über das jahresende hinaus
laufen zu lassen und sie haben auch
argumentiert dass dadurch eben kein
neuer atommüll entstehen was ist daran
falsch
in so schwierigen entscheidungsprozessen
es ist immer wichtig dass man fakten
grundlagen gegen schlips er geht ja sind
ja nicht ohne grund aus der atomkraft in
deutschland ausgestiegen jetzt sind wir
in einer notsituation wo wir uns alles
nochmal anschauen deswegen auch dort hat
robert habeck mit der umweltministerin
steffi lemke ja zusammen wer bereits
einen ersten test gemacht ob es helfen
würde mit blick auf atomkraftwerke wir
sind zu dem schluss damals gekommen
gerade mit strom atomkraftwerke
produzieren ja strom und wir haben vor
allen dingen die herausforderung mit der
versorgungssicherheit bei gas das
brauchen wir in dem bereich zusätzliche
unterstützung atomkraft macht 56 prozent
überhaupt ein kleiner teil sprechen
kleinemas wahnsinn fünf bis sechs
prozent stromversorgung aus wir reden
über den standort bayern das heißt das
kraftwerk macht weniger aus und all das
steckt jetzt robert habeck aber ich
möchte an dieser stelle also ich meine
wir sind ja nicht in einer situation wo
alles friede freude eierkuchen ist
sondern auch in so einer schwierigen
situation da gibt es massive interessen
und natürlich gibt es einige im land die
schon immer gesagt haben sollten
atomkraft einsteigen möchte ich meinen
hut vor der burg der sein licht nicht
dass man das tut was notwendig und
richtig ist und nicht das wo man denkt
das ist ein placebo am ende winkt das
einfach gar nicht lassen sie mich jemand
hinter der sehr glaubwürdiges rebecca
harms wird zu den grünen der ersten
stunde und hat damals im wendland den
widerstand gegen atomkraft organisiert
und heute sagt sie es darf in der
diskussion zitat keine heiligen kühe
geben und die drei deutschen
atomkraftwerke sollen ende des jahres
nicht abgeschaltet werden sehen sie das
völlig anders ja das sehe ich
das und wir haben ja auch mit blick auf
die drei atomkraftwerke ohnehin die
betreiber die das betreiben haben wir
etliche schon erklärt dass das nicht
funktioniert aber das ist nicht mein
mein haupt themenfeld das anschließende
dass der aussicht auf die drei
atommeiler länger am netz bleiben
deswegen überprüft robert habeck er in
einem zweiten stresstest genau noch mal
die situation und die ergebnisse
die warten wir aber ich möchte noch mal
deutlich machen also schlicht in einer
gaskrise hören wird so ich finde es
nicht für den richtigen schritt auf der
faktenlage die ich gerade kenne und mit
blick auf das was unsere herausforderung
ist unsere herausforderung dass deswegen
ist atomkraft nicht die antwort auf eine
gasversorgung und zugleich ist es ebenso
wie gesagt dass wir nicht beschlüsse
dieses land gemeinsam beschlossen hat
einfach so zurücknehmen auch bei der
frage kohlereserven ist ja ganz klar
dass wir gesagt haben es ist erstmal
eine reserve für den strombereich und
diesen schritt sind wir als
bundesregierung gemeinsam und
geschlossen gesehen nicht dass atomkraft
hier die antwort ist aber es ist auf ich
hab dazu jetzt alles gesagt